Welcome back everyone this is my new Venom
Let There Be Carnage post credit scene video
for all the big reports you guys have been
asked me about There's been all this talk
about a massive post credit scene.
Because there was a recent screening so i'll
explain what's going on andTom Hardy himself
has been posting a lot of Spider-Man related
pictures as well as Andy Serkis confirming
big Spider-Man crossover movies.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos.
The movie is coming out everywhere in a couple
weeks I'll be doing a bunch of videos for it
I'll try to keep this video as non-spoilery
as possible.
Just because there's so much stuff going around
and Tom Hardy himself seems like he's doing
everything he can enjoy the spoiler Bros.
But recently you probably saw there was a
special fan screening a Venom Let There Be
Carnage in the UK Tom Hardy in the director
Andy Serkis were there hyping the movie up.
It was after that screening last week that
all these reports about the post credit scene
started posting even Sony's official Twitter
account posted about the post credit scene
one of the people that was at the special
screening tweeted a bunch of hype about this
huge and credit scene in the Sony account
used their tweet for its own marketing for
a little bit before they deleted the tweet
like oh if they're talking at the post credit scene
Maybe we shouldn't be posted this to artificial
Sony account.
The retweet that they deleted just read now.
And my whole life.
I haven't seen the whole movie theater react
as loud as they did to the venom two and credit
scene Sony delivered I don't know why Sony
felt like that was spoiler he been they just
want people focusing on the and credit scene.
But also recently, Tom Hardy posted a picture
to his Instagram then quickly deleted it.
He's on this a couple times in the picture
he was wearing one of the crew hats from Spider-Man
No Way Home.
Yes, anybody can wear a hat from anywhere
that's not the spoiler he thing.
Here's why it's a big deal.
Is because you cannot buy those hats in stores,
they only give them to the people who worked
on Spider-Man No Way Home after the movie
is over.
Like as a gift.
Thanks for playing.
Here's a cool hat to remember us. You may
remember earlier this year a couple of the
Spider-Man No Way Home crew members posted
behind-the-scenes pics of them celebrating
in their crew gear that they gave everyone
after the movie was finished in they got in
big trouble for that time parties done this
in the past to where he post Spider-Man venom
pictures together and then quickly deletes
them.
But also recently around this fan screening
Tom Hardy and Andy Serkis confirmed that venom's
Spider-Man would be crossing over.
I we all knew that they would eventually because
Kevin Feige was talking about a couple years ago
This is them actually confirming that it's
happening.
So this is the clip of Tom Hardy talking about
how they're handling the multiverse or spider
verse since were talking about Spider-Man
characters is a venom verse you know the that
of this this spider verse there's multiverse.
There's all kinds of canon and lore amd mythology
to explore both laterally and forward in time
and I think with the right people and the right
planning it's about making the right choices
at the right time.
Even with foresight of understanding with
things may go. It's a combination of all those
and the alchemy of what it will be so
that conversation was basically him talking
about the next venom movie.
It will be called venom 3 it'll have a different
Spider-Man title what he talks about the alchemy
of the combination of the venom verse in the
spider verse he's talking about the MCU Spider-Man
movies, he's talking about doing a tom Holland's
Spider-Man crossover movie as the next big
venom movie in the lateral forward of it all
just means they haven't decided exactly where
in the timeline of the MCU movies.
It'll take place.
It'll jump forward a couple years or if the
movie will take place right after the events
of Spider-Man No Way Home.
But the title of that movie.
Whatever it winds up being the big crossover
would have Spider-Man and venom both in the title
So my early prediction is that the just because
Spider-Man the venom maximum carnage in the
just do the rest of the maximum carnage storyline
from the comics that they don't cover in Venom
Let There Be Carnage.
Because some of that movie is adapting aspects
of the maximum carnage storyline, but only
a little bit Spider-Man was a huge part of
the maximum carnage storyline.
So will be weird for them to do that whole
storyline without any Spider-Man it was basically
a giant venom, and Spider-Man team up story
against carnage where they put their differences
aside temporarily to get rid of, carnage,
so it should come as no surprise after all
this weird evidence is been coming out recently
that someone also posted a clip to read it,
claiming that it was the actual legit Venom
Let There Be Carnage post credit scene.
Now I can use the clip my video here because
if it's legit Sony could copyright my video.
So I want to take the risk because of the
recent Andrew Garfield Spider-Man No Way Home
deep fake scene you kind have to take things
like this with a grain of salt.
You may have seen recently there been all
the supposed pictures of Andrew Garfield reported
to be on the set of Spider-Man No Way Home
in they look kind of weird, like wow this
is like an actual scene.
But people are claiming it's from Spider-Man
No Way Home Andrew Garfield was recently on
late-night television say no way, man.
That's a deep fake.
That's not me see it and it's a Photoshop
we say no, then just a little while ago somebody
came out and claimed to be the artist who
made this as a deep fake claiming no no I
made this myself.
This is an actual scene.
It is a deep fake Andrew Garfield was not
lying this is not him because I created whole
cloth out of nothing.
It looks pretty legit.
Like if you didn't know how deepfakes work.
You might think this is a real scene that's
why anytime is a big league like this yet
to take with a grain of salt, which is based
on a lot of people who went to see the Venom
Let There Be Carnage early screening in the
UK in this audio clip that leaked out.
Based on these reports in the Venom Let There
Be Carnage seen Eddie Brock in venom supposedly
defeat, carnage, but don't kill him and then
recovering from the fight they go to a hotel
room to chill out.
But wind up stepping through a teleportation
circle nobody has said whether or not it's
one of Doctor strange is teleportation circles
they just say he's teleports usually don't
get specifics like this because the people
to go see the screenings are just casual fans
little give you the really big details like
this.
But based on the reports when they step through
the portal their hotel room looks exactly
the same except when they turn the TV on this
in the room tom Holland's Spider-Man is on
TV and the clip of him that's playing is the
Mysterio scene from Spider-Man far from home
post credit scene with Mysterio Doxxing him
in apparently the venom symbiote is supposed
to look at tom Holland's Spider-Man on TV
and safe and tasty.
Like he wants to eat Spider-Man as a snack
and then Eddie Brock supposedly says I hate
this guy and then they slammed the black and
that supposed to be the big post credit scene
that everybody's going crazy about so remember
you just have to take it with a grain of salt.
That could be real.
It could be fake.
But with all this
Tom Hardy walking around in the Spider-Man
No Way Home crew And he and Andy Serkis confirming
their next big movie with venom is going to
be the crossover movie.
It certainly makes it sound like this post
credit scene is real and if it is what that
means is their actually bringing venom into
the MCU to do the Spider-Man venom crossover
instead of tom Holland's Spider-Man traveling
the multiverse and going to the venom verse
for the movie, but you may remember just a
little while ago this year.
I did a video after Kevin Feige release this
huge preview info dump of all the marvel phase 4
movies are coming up in the Disney plus
series and during that people asked him about
venom coming into the MCU and he basically
revised his earlier statement say all you
know, that's totally possible now never say
never as a relates to any characters that
Marvel Studios hasn't brought screen yet having
been Marvel for 20 years I wouldn't dismiss anything
I wouldn't rule anything out when and how
and where remains to be seen.
Which I think is great that he's open to that
kind of thing now.
I totally don't mind venom mixing with the
MCU stuff as long as they let marvel have
some creative control and input on this big
Spider-Man crossover movie.
But what that means venom in the MCU and Tom
Hardy statements kind of back this up is that
venom will just be interacting with MCU characters
inside the Spider-Man movies like venom is
and then suddenly get show up in Val super
secret thunderbolts are dark avengers team
that she's putting together venom won't show
up during Captain America for or Avengers 5
When venom comes into the MCU.
It'll probably only be in the Spider-Man related
movies on a case-by-case basis 90 Tom Hardy
is wearing the Spider-Man No Way Home ball,
but I'm not expecting a ton of venom inside
that movie would've probably means is they're
just some Spider-Man No Way Home post credit
scene with venom to complete the teaser for
the crossover.
Like the Venom Let There Be Carnage post credit
scene at least one of the Spider-Man No Way
Home post credit scenes both make it clear
that venom has come into the MCU and will
meet Spider-Man.
Now just in terms of storyline for that big
crossover movie that they're doing.
Even though maximum carnage seems like the
logical thing for them to do is venom really
is coming into the MCU for the crossover if
they do maximum carnage that would mean the
carnage also has to come into the MCU.
And I'm not totally get a hold my breath on
that because it all depends on what happens
at the end of Venom Let There Be Carnage and
as of me posting this video I have not seen
the movie yet, so don't to speculate too much
about how the rest of the movie winds up ending
but honestly the end of the day.
I think we all knew that there were going
to cross these characters over it.
Which is a question of how they were going
to do and they're going to explain it in this
is all happening before the Loki series happen
in they have the Kang multiverse war that
they tease after the Loki series is see much
clearer like oh it just gonna be the multiverse
one of them will crossover from one of the
different universes and will just say that
all the venom movies are taking place in an
alternate universe.
So if you predicted a long time ago the venom
would come into the MCU eventually pat yourself
on the back, because you are correct.
Everybody let me know in the comments what
you think about this supposed post credit scene
Do you think it's real.
And what do you want them to do for the actual
story of the Spider-Man venom crossover.
Everybody post all your theories for the title
in the comments to the actual movie is coming
out in a couple weeks.
Of course will do a full post credit scene
video.
Once it does come out of full Easter eggs
breakdown video and then talk more about what's
going on with the big Spider-Man crossover
will get a new Spider-Man No Way Home trailer
in the next couple of months to everyone click
here to learn all about was going on with
the sinister six inside the Spider-Man No
Way Home trailer and click here for my brand-new
marvel eternals trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see in the next video!